here now is donald trump's attorney
elena along with fox news legal analyst
greg jarrett uh who by the way has a
must read column on foxnews.com exposing
a.g garland's dangerous behavior
let's talk about the double standard
alina i i gave a whole list of my
opening monologue tonight if you're a
conservative you're treated one way if
you're donald trump or a trump supporter
you're treated a very different way
here's the vice president
lecturing us
and she herself is telling rioters
they're not going to stop nor should
they stop she's the one promoting a bail
fund for the people involved so are we
supposed to really listen to her where's
that investigation
sean
if you use your first amendment right
we're going to come after you and call
you a domestic terrorist i just want you
to be prepared so you and i are going to
share a jail cell
that's basically what she said you know
don't disagree with us or we're going to
come after you this is not american this
is not american when are we done with
this everybody needs to get on the same
page cut the garbage and realize what
has happened to our country sore losers
cannot punish the right side of america
because we see the country for what it
is we are failing inflation is high
trump is leading in the polls if he quit
tomorrow this would all be done sean
this would be done i tell him all the
time you want to be done you want to
fire me get rid of me say you're not
running you will not leave lawyers
anymore you'll be done this is the most
sick version of our country i've ever
seen honestly you know greg we followed
all this closely this whole russia
collusion hoax narrative we've seen all
the raids on conservatives and then none
of the people responsible for lying to
fisa courts none of the people
responsible like hillary clinton you
know classified documents emails by the
way 33 000 deleted that would be called
obstruction where i grew up
never any accountability there's no
raids they've had hunter biden's laptop
for two years
we know there's evidence of crimes on
the laptop we know it implicates his
father the big guy and nobody seems to
care about that greg jarrett why
because there's no equal justice under
the law that's engraved on the pediment
of the united states supreme court
merrick garland has seen to that and so
is christopher wray in the fbi forgive
me if i just don't trust
the fbi that performed the warrant on on
trump's home the fbi has a long
and disgraceful record of lies and
concealment and manipulation you'll
recall that an fbi lawyer literally
doctored evidence in order to gain a
warrant to spy on the trump campaign the
fisa court excoriated the fbi when they
discovered it and banished all fbi
officials from ever appearing before
them those that were involved the
inspector general at the doj then
conducted an exhaustive investigation
going through hundreds of similar cases
and found
a shameful pattern of lies manipulation
concealment by the fbi in order to
secure warrants
to spy and to seize documents take a
look at this particular warrant that was
served uh at trump's home it is a
general search warrant which is most
often held to be unconstitutional
warrant unconstitutional warrants are
supposed to be narrowly confined
specific places to search and specific
items to be seized this was a
free-for-all go on in there grab
whatever you want turn the place upside
down ransack it and i think that was the
whole purpose of merrick garland and the
fbi to go in there and try to find
something anything to implicate
donald trump in any conceivable crime
perhaps some
imagined seditious conspiracy related to
the rioters on january 6. that's the
truth of what's going on here i think
and that would be the pretext
of all this alina as the president's
attorney do you want the affidavit of
merrick garland to be made public i know
the president has said he wants
everything made public
absolutely i want to see what is there
you know don't forget we have the
hillary suit that we're still pursuing
we have motions to dismiss pending
i want to know why rosenstein why schiff
why all these actors are held to a
different standard than republicans i am
sick and tired of seeing the
constitution be used differently
depending on your politics that is
anti-american i want to see what's in
that affidavit what the basis was when
you have a cooperating a cooperating
president who had no problem letting you
into his home
twice before what is your justification
for a raid two months later and three
months after you get the warrant with
the judge who recused himself from my
hillary case i want to understand that
all right helena thank you greg jarrett
as always thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else